oh no i'm gonna feel obligated to play
for you guys
ooh good acoustics in here what's up gq
i'm jacqueline grazer and these are my
10 essentials
so this is my chapstick there's a bunch
of different flavors of
scents of this chapstick this is the
minted rose one
this is a fairly new one i've never used
this one before but it's beautiful like
the colors
it's just beautiful up to you to tell me
if it looks rose on my lips or if my
lips look rosy either way i'm flattered
the smell is just like nostalgic to me
this smell reminds me it's like smells
like babies
or so like being a baby or like smelling
like baby lotion
or something baby scented oh my gosh
it's just like so soothing it smells
like it smells like
preschool it smells like preschool
these are my headphones ah the age-old
problem
i feel like the classical conventional
earbuds
are louder than airpods my mom always
gets mad except when i fall sleep in the
car like she can hear the music going
through
because i play it so loudly i use these
every single day i use these when i
travel whenever i'm just like
idle sitting or doing my homework
sometimes or trying to
not listen to someone or something i
put these in my ears and i crank it up
if i leave the house without these
then i'm gonna be bummed for the rest of
the day even though they get tangled in
my
keys and even though it's hard to skate
in them and walk in them because they
get caught in things and then they fall
out of my ear and i get a little bit
aggravated
i like these more because they're louder
and it's humble
it's like i'm not showing you that i
look i have gold-plated air pods from
straight from the apple store in dubai
i have these that are tangled and
went through the washing machine these
are my four rings
i love the kind of rings that aren't
like jewelry
it's just like it's just metal i like it
because it makes my finger it turns my
finger green
and it's and it's kind of grimy and it
looks like it's made out of pewter and
it was like found and
dug up somewhere this is one actually
that my girlfriend gave to me before we
were dating
and i've just been wearing it since this
one i got in mexico from a fan
in monterrey and she was so sweet i
liked it because it was made it's made
from a bearing
so that one goes here last but not least
my girlfriend gave me this one as well
it says j plus c on the inside of it
because her name is celia
it's just a beautiful ring i think it's
really beautiful and so i put it on on
this finger
and that's just that's just kind of like
a dominating feeling
makes me feel better about having
headphones with wires this is my
fisheye lens i skateboard so i take
skate videos
i like put that there and it's like
fisheye this is the future of filmmaking
filming someone taking a selfie i love
fish eye effect
i love that kind of thing fisheye in the
face
this year i started in a film production
class but i've been doing this forever
i've been
making like skits and videos and stuff
but i don't use the fish eye as much as
i'd like to but i always have it on me
just in case just to be safe if i want
to film someone up close
like oh dude you got a great nose for
this fish eye i don't say that to them
but
in my head that's what i'm thinking
these are my keys so kids are now
putting their keys on their belt
i'm the one who started that trend in
fifth grade i started doing this
anyway just had to clear that up this i
got in um in florence italy
when i was filming the show we are who
we are at the museum where the statue of
david is
it says firenze italia then another
really like this
is the essential part i could go without
the keys i just need this thing and
people are like oh no do you have a
screwdriver on you and i'm like or do
you have a bottle opener
do you have a serrated edge and i'll be
like
oh but then this carabiner this is a
special carabiner because it does this
it's not that special but it does this
so you can like make sure it doesn't
open by itself
this is a jaw harp it's an instrument
that
came from asia i don't actually i'm not
too clear in the history but
when i play it you'll know like it's
like it sounds like an american staple
kind of thing
listen
you know so i like this thing it's
obscure and i'm and i guess i'm obscure
oh my god i'm so obscure
and it comes in this little case and you
can put it around your neck if you want
but i don't do that that's kind of too
flashy for me
i'm not a big gloat about the jaw harp i
keep it on the down low
air maze cologne intense vetted
this is actually the first time i've
gotten this uh
model species version
i usually get the ones that are like
colored my favorite one is the red one
but recently i got into this one and
it's really nice it has notes of
patchouli
and it's got kind of like a rugged thing
it also induces an amplification of
self-esteem
it feels good to smell good when i was a
little precocious little nine-year-old i
was obsessed with colognes it made me
feel adult it was like my
my form of like little young baby
rebellion not smelling like
chocolate pudding but smelling like air
maze actually had more cologne then than
i do now
i have one bottle of cologne now i
should have two one for date night and
one for business
mmm notes of extreme blast and body odor
it is degree i've tried like the ones
that have honey and oatmeal and
duh it feels like actually it makes me
it makes my armpit smell worse oh god i
sound really gross but whatever
it smells like my one of my really good
friends his armpits
i emulated him and and getting this
flavor
flavor my friend wyatt uh
uses this one when we were filming it he
was growing hair on his legs
and on his arms and and his chest and
stuff and i had zero hair anywhere not
even on my head i had no hair
i was like oh when i when i get hair on
my armpits i'm going to use
exactly what he uses and i and i am five
years later
i've been through a lot of speakers in
my day but nothing beats any speaker
like bugani
these things vibrate unbelievably and
and it's insane i don't really play that
kind of music though but it's loud
it's not waterproof i'm not asking for
to be waterproof frankly
honestly i just want something that's
loud but also small
enough so i can carry it like this this
thing has seen a lot of places
uh it's been to the beach it's been up
in the mountains
it's like falling down mountains it's
been left at gas stations before
i use it in my house and in the morning
sometimes on a saturday morning my mom
gets mad at me for this
but i like open my window all the way
and i make it
facing outwards and i'll like blast like
led zeppelin or like grateful dead or
something
it's not music that you could ever say
you don't want to hear i think maybe
that's subjective
i don't know how people could be like oh
my god turn that rubbish off because
like there's
there's nothing wrong with it this is my
yamaha flute
i started playing the flute four years
ago i never took any lessons
my dad plays the flute and i really
loved
jethro toll growing up so then i really
wanted to
learn how to play i don't know how to
read sheet music but i would like like
go on youtube and like watch like live
videos of jethro tall and like look at
his fingers and like
see what he did with his fingers and
it's a hard thing to kind of keep up
with but once you you figure it out you
uh it's like it's easy
i suck right now because i'm tired but
keep in mind i never took a lesson
so yes i skateboard and when i went to
madrid for a convention
i got the coolest board ever
this is not it when i went to madrid for
the first time i
did a convention and i went to this
skate shop called welcome skate shop and
there's a guy there
jura damager such a cool guy he made me
a board
and i got the cool deck and like the
grip was really cool because it was
half green half black trucks were like
these thunder
it was like this thunder collab that i
couldn't even post about because i
wasn't released yet
it was the coolest board i'd ever
received in my life
and also i learned all the the greatest
tricks i've ever learned i learned on
that board
and of course it had to get stolen
stupidly enough
i left it at school on friday and it was
there the whole weekend
and then i came back and it wasn't there
but also it's annoying because that same
thing did
happen to me and i left a board that i
kind of didn't care about that was kind
of trashed and like it was chipping in
it was kind of grody
no one stole it this is not the board
but it's still a
really awesome board nonetheless it
rides real well probably because you're
the damager made it
judah the damager that's his instagram
name it's a really good board i got this
recently for my 17th birthday
it rides real well but in all honesty i
don't know if anything will ever beat
that board that the first board that i
got in madrid
alright gq that's it thank you for
checking out my essentials
love you